é
pour les premiers acheteurs.
Vérifications des faits
avec Mathieu Prost.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les logements sociaux et
abordables, c'était une priorité
pour l'administration Plante.
Elle en voulait 12 000,
6000 de chaque.
Et cette année, la promesse
a été multipliée par 10.
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate mairie
de Montréal, Projet Montréal
- La construction de 60 000
logements abordables au cours
des prochaines années.
- Mais les 12 000 promis
ont-ils été livrés?
Si on se fie au total fourni
par la Ville, il en manque moins
de 500. Sauf que la promesse,
c'est de mettre ces logements
à disposition des Montréalais.
Et de ce point de vue,
l'objectif est loin
d'être atteint.
Pour 4000 logements sociaux,
seul 1 sur 4 est actuellement
occupé. C'est mieux pour
le logement abordable : on parle
de 80 % de taux d'occupation.
L'autre stratégie pour limiter
l'exode des familles
vers la banlieue, c'était
de réduire les dépenses
lors d'un premier achat.
"Plus de bienvenue, moins
de taxes", disait le slogan.
Le remboursement d'une partie
des droits de mutation devait
initialement bénéficier à 20 000
familles lors de la promesse.
Un chiffre revu à la baisse
à 12 000 quand le mécanisme
a été mis en place.
Finalement, sur les 4 années
du mandat, moins de 6000 ménages
en ont bénéficié.
La faute en grande partie
aux plafonds trop bas.
Par exemple, il fallait
que votre triplex vous ait
coûté moins de 630 000 $
pour être admissible.
- On va obliger les promoteurs,
les constructeurs à faire
du logement abordable,
du logement social
et du logement familial.
- Là encore, les ambitions
du règlement pour une métropole
mixte, le 20-20-20,
ont été revues à la baisse.
L'exigence de 20 % de logement
social est maintenue.
Mais les 20 % de logement
abordables peuvent finalement
descendre à 10 %.
Et jusqu'à 5 % pour
le logement familial.
Le règlement n'est en vigueur
que depuis le 1er avril 2021,
trop tôt pour dire
si ces contraintes
poussent les promoteurs
vers la banlieue de Montré